[Music]
I remember when he died I was a little
boy and I went to the wake with my aunts
and I was kneeling out of the casket and
I was looking at him inside the casket
and I started thinking about my
flashlight
started thinking about
thinking about using side
when I said to my aunt Maybe maybe he's
just in the wrong way
this morning Steven Wright Rolling Stone
ranked him the 15th greatest comedian of
all time his extra dry deadpan style has
made him can't miss stand up since the
1970s over the decades Wright has
written tens of thousands of jokes but
now he's out with his first novel called
Harold published by Simon Schuster a
part of Paramount global like everything
else Wright does it is Holy unique
I get outside get in my car and driving
out to the store my mind is skipping
around and wondering how my life would
have been different had I been born one
day earlier that I'm thinking maybe it
wouldn't have been different other than
I would ask that question yesterday
I think abstract I'm into surrealism and
Abstract stuff and then it like it
combined into this style but I didn't
sit down I didn't have meetings with
myself how can I make a certain Style
this is how I speak and that's how I
think and it's another and it's just
meshed together by accident
true to form Stephen Wright's first book
began as something else
a series of tweets I didn't want to put
jokes on Twitter because I just thought
to me a joke is an alive thing to be
said to an audience so then I thought
I'm just gonna keep writing it as a book
not write it on Twitter I went to a
museum where they had all the heads and
arms from the statues that are in all
the other museums
right who grew up in Massachusetts
honed his unmistakable Style on the
comedy circuit in the late 1970s first
appearance on national television and uh
I think you're going to find him a
little different his career took off
when Johnny Carson booked him on The
Tonight Show in 1982. I get up the other
day and everything in my apartment had
been stolen and replaced with an exact
replica
I remember when I was in the womb
it was over on the right okay we'll
carry on with this next week over time
his stand-up shows were supplemented
with an Oscar this is the short film
category and where really glad that we
cut out the other 60 minutes
well you know this
and dozens of movie appearances most
famously the voice of radio DJ K Billy
in Reservoir Dogs Joe Egan and Jerry
Rafferty were a Duo known as dealers
wheel when they recorded this Dylan
asked pop bubble gum favorite from April
of 1974. but none of it happened before
Wright was able to conquer one
all-consuming fear how long did it take
you to get over stage fright uh slowly
after like
several years three or four years
where I got to be like not it wasn't as
as intense but it's not normal it's not
it's not the same as me and you just
sitting here
talking so I'm relaxed to a point
that it's not going to get more relaxed
it's like I'm used to doing something
that's not normal to do I'm used to the
this is crazy part of Wright's New
Normal became working on Harold
how is the process of writing a book for
you different than the process of
writing jokes the jokes come into my
mind just from doing my daily hanging
out or whatever I'm doing I notice
things that come out as joke oh that
could be like that like I just from
really noticing the world but the book
was purposely working on it for a couple
of hours focused on this exact subject
so that was different for me I liked
doing it because it was stuff I would
have never thought of if I wasn't
sitting down focused Harold is a
seven-year-old boy growing up in the
1960s the book is a Wandering Journal
into his non-stop mind what Wright
describes as Birds constantly flying
into his brain I put a funnel on his
head and I was pouring into his head
everything I think about life that
couldn't be said as jokes on stage so
I'm using him to say what I think of
this whole experience is Harold you
part of it is yeah
do you think you have more birds than
most people
yes yeah I mean I'm not bragging but yes
no I think so I kind of feel the same
way it's not you do yeah
and I guess you just have to figure out
how to harness it yes yeah because you
you can only contr you only have so much
control of what you're thinking about
but then you do have control on what you
do with what you're thinking about where
you organize it or Focus you know
everyone is just wandering around like
an insane asylum walking down the street
with Just Thoughts
anxiety and restlessness are still
things that are unavoidable for right
especially on stage
and broke a mirror in my house I'm
supposed to get seven years bad luck but
my lawyer thinks he can get me five
it's exaggerated everything good is
amazing everything bad is horrible you
know it has its highs and lows when you
say some joke you think is hilarious and
there's 800 people just staring blankly
at you
you have to uh act like oh you're not
phased I'm not faced by that but the
inside of your head you're going oh my
God and I can't predict what they're
gonna laugh at even after all these
years you think that maybe maybe me I am
crazy
on a scale of one to ten six being the
highest
Herald
Wright asks if it's possible to be in
your seventies and have the perspective
of a child
without being nuts
you're almost in your 70s
what do you think
I think it's well I don't think I'm nuts
but I think that you can still have the
wonderment of a child like why is
everything and it didn't wear off for me
[Music]
we met Stephen Wright at the Strand in
New York City on Independent bookstore
day which is fitting he's actually going
to be at the Strand coming up this
Thursday if you want to meet him but
this book is different let me just say
that just as is he yes as is this you
know going in but it I just thought it
was interesting where he said all the
stuff he couldn't say on stage he wanted
to say somewhere so he said it here